and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists thank you so much for
joining us welcome today to episode 159
today we're gonna talk about well we're
gonna talk about Black Friday but really
what we're gonna talk about is the so
called most wonderful time of the year
it's the most wonderful time of the year
it's the it's the holiday shopping
season it used to just be the holiday
season yeah we turn Christmas time into
Christmas presents well dude we turn the
holiday season into the holiday shopping
season dude if we can find a way to make
money off of it as a society that's
typically the way that we will go yeah
and there's nothing inherently wrong
with making money but when we when it's
the primary drive when that's the main
focus you won't you spoil you know and
otherwise you know nice time of the year
where people feel warm and fuzzy and
you've got Christmas music playing and
people building snowmen and sledding
like I remember I just remember
Christmas it was different when I was a
kid man and I understand that I was a
kid so that's why Christmas it's one of
the main reasons why Christmas was
different but but but it definitely
wasn't I feel like it wasn't as
commodified commodified commercialized
but even then I mean it was it was it
was the beginnings of it really I mean
especially in the 80s when we just
started bringing in all the 80s and in
the 90s but you and I grew up in the 80s
and we started bringing in all of these
really cheap goods from overseas and we
for the first time had these giant
discount stores whether it was I mean
Kmart was around before we were even
born but then
was the megastores like like Walmart
yeah and we we started placing emphasis
on the objects
it's the objectification of the holiday
season and what is the the premier
example of commodifying the holidays
it's that one day of the year Black
Friday now you and I we used to be in
retail and we manage a bunch of retail
stores and do you remember what it was
like just Thanksgiving Day for us even
we we got the day off yeah it was
miserable for me but why was it
miserable well dude I we had to be at
work at 4 o'clock in the morning the
following day on Black Friday
yeah because their stores open at 6 or 7
or whatever they open in the morning but
we had to be at work at 4 so we could go
around to the neighboring retail stores
that also had their Black Friday sales
anchor stores yes and we would go there
to their lines where people were camped
out and hanging out waiting for the
stores to open and we would hand out
coffee and doughnuts and of course
flyers directing them to our store after
long yes with coupons directing them to
our store after they after they did
their initial Black Friday shopping its
we were we were totally cool with being
sloppy seconds
what's what three months sucked is
because on Thanksgiving like I
specifically remember go to my grandma's
house one year we're having an awesome
Thanksgiving
we're playing euchre like it's just it's
or haven't you know just a good family
time but then like 6:00 p.m. rolled
around and I'm like oh I have to go home
and go to bed now like you have to get
up crazier right like I can't I can't
really stay here and enjoy this
experience with you this is one of the
three days off that you know we had a
year right it was like I couldn't even
enjoy it because it was cut short
because I had to get up so early for
Black Friday it's weird because we would
go to those big-box stores to Target and
Best Buy and Kohl's and all of these
these places Sears that used to be a
store oh my god and we would hand out
those coupons mm-hmm
it was it's the one time one day of the
year where people are such they're so
frantic they're in a frenzy of
consumerism yeah that they'll happily
accept it's the one day we're not
they'll just say yeah give me your
stupid coupon go away they happily say
yes give me whatever deals you have yeah
what cheap plastic things can you sell
me today and as long as I get a discount
then I want in I feel like I'm part of
and it's weird it's it's it's the worst
kind of tribalism in a way where we
where we surround ourselves with people
whose common goal is to buy things they
don't need and then we get sucked into
it well it's not even the well I
shouldn't say it's not even but I
thought so a piece of it is buying stuff
we don't need but another piece of a
2-man is people love the hunt mmm
they love the deals man like I can't
tell you how many times I've seen
someone you know they go to one Black
Friday wait a customer coming to our
retail store into the cell phone store
and they were talking about how they got
like 15 HDMI cables for like you know
five bucks because of this Black Friday
special mixed with I mean it was just
ridiculous and I'm like what do you do
with all those well I don't know I got
extra cables now I mean someone needs
when I could give him to him wow what
what it but it's but it was the thrill
of the hunt it really wasn't the HDMI
cable right it was this thrill of I'm
getting something for free or I'm
getting something at a at a heavily
discounted rate therefore I am you know
somehow am I I am jumping up with my
finances because I've saved all this
money right right what and the truth is
that you've spent all this money you
haven't saved money it's right yeah it's
a hundred percent off if you refuse to
buy it yes otherwise you are actually
parting with your money and that's what
retailers and advertisers do really well
especially this time of year I know with
our retail stores in the telecom
industry that we were in at the time
between Thanksgiving and in the end of
the year so those six weeks or so forty
percent of our profits for that year
were with at that time of year was
responsible for 40% of the annual profit
yeah that's how important that's that's
why they call a Black Friday it's then
it's the time of year where the the
retail stores go from red to black on
their books because the frenzy commences
and then we start playing around in fact
I remember starting in February is when
we started having holiday planning
meetings every single week so we could
talk about the marketing and advertising
and staffing everything led up to those
six weeks of the year is fun that's so
true man it's like 10 months of the year
it was just as build up yeah we worked
really hard for 10 months to to try to
extract as many dollars as we could from
your checking account or if you didn't
have your checking account that was okay
because you had credit cards you could
put it on right yeah and so that's what
we're gonna be talking about today I
want to throw in here too man lake there
because there's always exceptions to the
rule you know that I I've there's a
couple arguments I've heard about Black
Friday one is oh you know Black Friday
if you're making fun of Black Friday
you're really you're making fun of poor
people um I don't know that there was a
gentleman our Washington DC documentary
event and he was kind of giving us a
hard time for putting the Black Friday
stuff in there okay yeah so our
documentary starts out with with the
Black Friday but but you know I just
want to say that like I don't want to
undermine the fact that there might be
something that somebody got and they
could only afford to get it on Black
Friday but well but but that's an
exception to the rule the the rule is is
is no matter rich or poor it is all over
the demographics all are all over the
place with people who go and participate
with Black Friday sales oh yeah I mean
we saw that how many years do we manage
retail stores how many every single year
we had to work on Black Friday was no
question about right with the work the
entire weekend and I would often work 18
hours a day on Black Friday starting out
around 3:00 in the morning handing out
those coupons until the very close of
business later that day and and so I I
mean I experienced everyone is looking
for deals no matter where
the socio-economic ladder we had crazy
rich people showing up most of the
people who showed up however were just
your everyday middle-class people yeah
and and and it's because we get whipped
into a frenzy by advertising and and we
get what was the word we were talking
about on we were doing this behind the
scenes live on YouTube right before this
which was the most hilarious one of my
favorite things we do because they're
such hit-or-miss things but I was
reading this thing from Jack Handey and
the word was Hornswoggle and I feel like
people are being hornswoggled by
advertising I don't even know what is it
you know what Michael means no but it
feels right doesn't it yeah no they
definitely and the only reason I bring
that up man is because I really I'm just
trying to include all perspectives in
this conversation because I've heard a
lot of different perspectives but yeah I
mean I can't think of a perspective in
which that I can fully align myself with
the values of an inanimate corporate
body and and that's really what's going
on here we're being tricked into showing
up early to camping out at night to save
20 or 30 or 40 dollars on these things
when the truth is that some of these
things that were buying we'd be better
off without them yeah no I totally agree
and so let's let's talk about that today
we're diving into some of these holiday
shopping questions and our first
question is from Ann Marie and Buffalo
what Friday approaches and he has come
out a lot of the anxiety starts to
commence I've always been the primary
shopper in my house and over the past
few years I've altered showing up for
the Black Friday so it was no longer
becoming enjoyable the wines were way
too long and the cells weren't even that
great it was taken away time for my
family it was exhausting over the years
I have seen Black Friday's turn into
black Thursdays where this consumerism
became a priority over spending
Thanksgiving with family and friends it
soon became a sport for the family and
instead of enjoying people it's an gravy
with the grandparents it's more about
who's going and get in line to grab the
news shiny right thing at 5 p.m. and
first Amana Thanksgiving Day over the
years I've resorted to online shopping
but I found every year it's just getting
more stressful and less enjoyable and
not to mention if the stress of going
into that looming into January is
daunting
my daughter is 10 and is an only child
and has all the things she could ever
want more Santa always brings the quote
unquote the big gift this year there's
nothing more to give she wants things
that she will soon stop playing list or
lose interest six months from now
so our road to minimalism as a family is
fairly new and the concept is still
fresh and raw with our family my
question is how do you talk to a 10 year
old about asking for things of value
that she really doesn't understand
herself so I think here's the important
thing to know building off of what you
were just talking about a moment ago
Ryan with respect to socioeconomic class
or whatever I don't think it matters
where you are in life if the holidays or
if Christmas time is stressing you out
if it's making you and your family
anxious whether you're 10 years old or a
hundred and ten years old then you might
be doing the holidays wrong mm-hmm and I
know this from personal experience
because I did the challah I was I was
the ultimate consumer and also the
peddling of consumerism the peddler of
consumerism with with respect to living
in the retail world managing a ton of
retail stores it was my job to get you
to buy stuff I didn't care how much debt
you had to go into I didn't care what
kind of car you drove what kind of house
you were in where you worked whether or
not you had a job I didn't care if it
made you anxious or didn't make you
anxious it was my job to get that money
out of you one way or another and more
the better what was the what was the the
big thing that we would track Ryan
upsells all the stop signs
yeah bolt ons we always need we were 29
different metrics for which we were
responsible for and so you wanted a
customer comes in to buy item a you want
in the buy item BCDE all the way to Z
and then I guess Double A and BB
with our 29 items total that's part of
it that's part of the whole sales
process man like we would have secret
secret shoppers go in there
and one of the questions we would ask
the secret shopper was worried what
other products and services were you
offered while you were in the store
right how many times were you asked yes
I mean it's it's crazy man and and so
yeah we were know was not enough we had
to find a different way around the the
first no and ii know eventually we got
to the third no or hopefully a yes so
yes we were responsible in a way it
wasn't our intention to create anxiety
although i come to think about it it it
might have been slightly part of our our
aim to create some sort of stress called
excitement it's like faux excitement
well we definitely were creating stress
just with the black friday sale hey you
have to be here at this time to get this
deal doorbuster sales you're not here
then you're gonna miss out on this deal
right yeah yeah and so we did want to
create a false sense of urgency which
amped up the stress levels the anxiety
levels and the only way to it's a sort
of step back from that is to realize the
absurdity of this there's an essay in a
book that I'm gonna give Amory this
essay is called sales price is fool's
price from our book essential there's an
essay collection with 150 different
essays and in one of them is called
fool's price but you know it's funny
amory she's the leader at the Buffalo
meetup group yeah meetup group yeah and
literally we just sent her a copy of
essentials for the group so Emery will
be sending you a second copy of
essentials but ya know that's a great
essay yeah and so I think in in the book
well there's an a whole chapter on on
stuff and there's another chapter on
success and we talk about one of these
things about price and for me I avoid
sale price whenever possible now it
doesn't mean that I saying no keep your
discount I don't want it
right it means I will not make the sale
price the deciding factor
they're in my purchase yeah it's not
going to you're not gonna let a sales
price or sell an item on sale make you
impulsively buy that item yeah right
yeah and I think yeah like if you need a
pair of jeans and you go to you know
mission workshop and they're like hey
we've got a Black Friday 20% off Cyber
Monday and you need the jeans right like
you're not gonna just throw away money
for the sake of it exactly but if I get
an email from Mission Workshop and
they're like act now it's cyber monday
you're like maybe I need think about
maybe get the pair jeans in the next six
months to a year I should just get them
now that's the wrong deciding factor
absolutely it's encouraging me to buy
something that I otherwise wouldn't buy
yeah because it's not just the pair of
jeans you're gonna make that decision
with yeah so I'd rather pay full price
than fool's price yeah is the the
ultimate lesson from that si but but
let's let's talk a little bit more about
this here so how does that what does she
do for her ten-year-old I mean it's it's
uh it's something that you know not
having kids first off I can give great
advice on this just get rid of the kit
no it's it's something though I do think
about when Mariah and I have kids I do
want to make Christmastime special for
these kids um I mean I want to make
every day special but I understand the
novelty with Christmas and I'm not you
know I don't want to be all bah humbug
right so I don't know man how do you
what do you do with Ella how do you not
just have Christmas Day with her but how
do you help her appreciate the value of
things well so she asked about values in
particular and a ten-year-old doesn't
have values they were about your your
values are reflected on to them know as
a parent you know they adopt your values
whether you like it or not now good and
bad now ten year olds have beliefs right
LoZ five but but ten year olds have a
set of beliefs that are that tend to be
similar to your beliefs at this point
now pretty soon they're gonna hit
puberty and they're their beliefs will
radically diverge from what your beliefs
are their beliefs are gonna be so horny
yes
and and well they'll just be hormonal in
general too right and so in fact their
beliefs will almost be a direct opposite
of whatever yours are but but ultimately
their values the core values will be the
same those gonna have some different
beliefs about how to get to those values
so right now it's about instilling
whatever your values are the only way
you can do that is to get really clear
on what your values are first if you
don't know your values are it's hard to
communicate those express those to your
son or daughter now here's the thing I
will say is that consumerism should
never be a priority during any season
whether it's the holiday season or
birthdays or whatever however it has
become paramount and has become the
priority of the holiday season have you
got all of your Christmas shopping done
have you checked everything off of your
Christmas list it's become a to-do list
buying gifts for people yeah but is it
something very much fun no and it sounds
like the wrong kind of value system as
well there's nothing wrong with getting
gifts in fact we'll make sure that we
get all awesome gifts for Christmas but
you know what else I'll get our gifts
just on a random day
hey it's January 17th I got you this
thing because you were really good this
week and you earned it it's also okay to
have grace and understand that maybe you
didn't earn a gift but I can give you a
gift just because I love you or I think
this will add value to your life but
it's also good to set up a system of
earning with with your children but when
it comes to the holidays yeah your kids
are gonna want some stuff but their
value what they value or is different
from their values but what they value
right now you're right it might change
six months from now but a long enough
timeline is definitely gonna change so
what if it changes six months from now
so what if it changes six years from now
I guarantee you you get them a gift at
age ten they're probably not going to
still like that gift at age 16 and so
you're gonna have to come to terms with
something that you get them now is
eventually going to stop adding value I
mean you're like I'd say that about
clothes I mean you know you buy a
two-year-old pair of shoes how long has
it take for them to grow out of their
shoes
I claim we're gonna grow out of our
things and even as adults Ryan you and I
grow out of our thing absolutely and so
we have to think of those things as
temporary the question then becomes like
what are you comfortable with what what
time frame are you comfortable with
because yeah maybe six months from now
she's gonna be tired of that toy and if
if you want to donate it someone else
great or if you don't want to get it we
said this on the previous episode about
excess but like missing out it was the
fear episode missing out is really it
just letting go in advance the joy of
letting go Joel oh wait no and and
there's this coffee ring on the table
that is driving me crazy I'm crazy um
all right well let do you want to take a
no no you can keep going so so you
talked about the six-month thing and
I'll tell you man the the thing that
always stands out to me when people ask
about kids is I always think about that
the line from Joshua Becker's book
clutter-free with kids and it's it's the
line that says we don't want to tell our
kids what to do you don't want to like
be a dictator but you do want to set
boundaries for your kids so the question
is and Maria what are the appropriate
boundaries for your ten-year-old up into
this point it sounds like the floodgate
has kind of been open with Christmas and
gifts so now you have to start setting
these boundaries I'll be honest if
they're expecting so right this episode
is gonna come out on Black Friday the
Tuesday before Tuesday before Black
Friday so right now might be the wrong
time to start setting those boundaries
for a ten-year-old meaning if they've
led if it's led up to this point and and
they've had this expectation of what
Christmas should be to change it a month
before Christmas you know I don't know
if that's just something that Amory can
do great if not then I totally
understand that too because again like
if this is coming out right before Black
Friday this kid is expecting Christmas
to be a certain way so what do you do it
now or whether you do it for next
Christmas and Maury set boundaries up
what do those look like is it a one in
one out ruled you explained your your 10
year old hey I'm happy to get you
Christmas guess I'll get you whatever
you want that you're gonna get sick of
in six months how
ever we need to get rid of just as many
things as what we're bringing into the
house I know I know a lot of I don't
know a lot but I know a few families who
they they do these decluttering parties
essentially as a family after Christmas
where they have you know just a ton of
toys and they've got you know a toy
chest with toys in there mm-hmm so in
the process of combining the toys they
don't just you know buy a bigger toy box
they actually will go through and get
rid of toys that they don't play with
anymore I mean they do they do a very
deliberate decluttering you could do
something like that because your kids
are gonna get value from some toys of
course having the appropriate amount
you know Ella and I did a video on our
YouTube channel about this and and the
average kid has about 300 toys in the
United States but plays was just 12
daily and so I'm not saying that your
kid should have only 12 toys maybe some
of them should and by the way it's
different for each kid Ella doesn't even
like that many toys and so it's easier
for me to have fewer toys now could that
be that she reflects our values that's
probably a part of it but she also
enjoys doing things do doing things as
opposed to owning things so what kind of
so what kind of boundaries have you and
back set up for Ella when it comes to
presence have you had to set any
boundaries up have you had to basically
explain to her hey look this is a line
we're not crossing yeah yes so quite
often what we do is the boundaries that
we set up or past our own comfort zones
so there's a there's an example there's
like this little stool outside the front
door that that Ella likes to put like
sticks and rocks and random things on
she has a little stick collection and
for me it's stupid why the hell would
you want to like collect sticks I mean
is she just trying to rub it in my face
that she's not a minimalist but no like
she likes having this little but she
knows that it can't go past the the
literal boundaries of this little stool
that assets on yeah we can't say all
right well that one's full let's get a
second stool out here or great let's get
a bigger stool and so there's a literal
found physical boundary there the other
boundaries have to do with what with
what she holds on to meaning we
constantly reevaluate the things that
she is using so had how do you explain
those boundaries to her the best way to
explain it is is when she donates
something she has to understand where
it's going it's not just going to the
goodwill it's going to some other kid
who is going to start playing with it
because she's not playing with it
anymore and by the way by letting go of
it now she can bring something else in
that she will start playing with and so
instead of tell her what she can't have
or what she can't do or what she
shouldn't want we're letting her know
that by letting go you're making room
for something else yeah I love that man
it's what a good example with the the
stool and the sticks and the rocks
because yes you Josh don't want her
collecting sticks and rocks out 4-0
sticks around exactly but but setting up
these boundaries and saying yes and
instead of just you know looking at
someone and saying no so anne-marie what
boundaries can you set up for your kid
now that I think about I think I'm gonna
get rid of those stupid sticks alright
and Marie enjoy enjoy your copy of
essential it's an essay collection with
150 essays and it sounds like Ryan
already sent you the autographed book
but if you want the audio book as well I
feel like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of essential essays by
the minimalists Sean if you could reach
out to her and maybe see if she wants
the audiobook version of that I feel
like we're skipping over something
important here man oh yeah here's one
thing I would recommend yeah a debt-free
Christmas yeah that's a good one how
about that and not just for you but
teaching your kid about debt and money
we did this video with Rachael Cruz on
our YouTube channel put a link to this
in the show notes Sean about teaching
your kids to put their money in the
three bucket so if you if they ready to
get ten bucks from their allowance right
hmm
having a portion of it goes to giving
mm-hmm a portion of a ghost is saving
and a portion of it goes to spending the
spending thing can be on toys the giving
thing could be gifts for someone else or
the charity
and the saving could be saving for
something in their future so yeah you're
not gonna teach your ten-year-old about
a Roth IRA account just yet right but
you can teach him about the concept of
saving for the future I was what I was
thinking was is teaching your kid about
having experiences over things so Amory
could do this with her child whether
it's a family vacation or maybe it's leg
hey as a Christmas gift you get to stay
up a little later or maybe you give them
an extra bite of ice cream I don't know
I'm just like throwing some different
ideas out there but I think there are
ways you can certainly still give gifts
to your 10 year old give them things
that they're really gonna enjoy things
that's gonna be meaningful to them
without actually giving them something
that's cheaply made out of plastic yeah
I think I think that you can also wrap
those up as well with with Ella will
often wrap up experiences so if we're
gonna take her to Disneyland for example
you can put that in a box in an envelope
or several series of box boxes and she's
opening them all up minimalist and then
with that wrapping paper everywhere
there's like the excitement and when we
talked to Peter Rollins about the
difference between pleasure and
enjoyment and part of the experience of
the holidays of enjoying the experiences
of the holidays is the enjoyment the
anticipation that the the the gift under
the tree want one thing that we've done
with Ella several times in the past ago
Christmas tree hunting we were living in
Montana and and we go out we find the
right Christmas tree for five dollars
you get this this permit that you can
cut down basically that you know the
trees are infinite in Montana it's a
massive massive stable you go out and
you spend even after all those forest
fires there's still plenty of trees to
cut down for Christmas well that's the
thing like she would go and like want to
pick a burnt down tree like how about
this one did she see this hundred-foot
tree that's been there for a hundred
years can we get this one I'm like Ella
do you think that one will fit in our
living room no probably not and then
she'd go it's like a little Charlie
Brown tree and like you know it's it's a
twig that's coming out of the ground how
about we cut down this one and
eventually and that's part of the
experience so it's not just going to buy
a Christmas tree it's the entire it's
the it's the enjoyment of the entire
going out in the woods looking at trees
laughing at her stupid suggestions for
trees tweeting about her stupid
suggestions for trees you could follow
her on Twitter by the way she's at at LS
sandwich is her is her twitter handle
she says the craziest things and it's
our way that we catalogue everything
that she says instead of having a
scrapbook for Ella we have a Twitter
account and thousands of the you follow
her musings and Mon during's on Twitter
alright our next question today is from
Ryan and Dallas so this is me and my
wife's first holiday season as Mentalist
and we're not really struggling with
receiving gifts because both of our
family are willing to try to cut down on
what they give us
but we've been struggling with what to
get others just because we want to you
know give people the things that will
add value to their lives but with this
season it's so hard to think and figure
out what to do so I just wanted to hear
your thoughts on you know how do y'all
deter do y'all even give gifts or if you
do how do you know exactly what to get
them is it best to do like a gift card
you know it's just kind of hard to
figure out from my side of how to give
the best gift that I can give without
going overboard or doing too much or too
little all right man Ryan wants us to do
the thinking for him why not we need to
pay out gifts for his friends and family
the first thing is have you considered
minimalism live a meaningful life it
makes a great stocking stuffer and all
your minimalism questions will be
answered let me tell you that if you
give out our book not only will people
be thankful but they'll live a more
meaningful life
if only give all Ryan came out was
copies of minimalism Christmas why here
it was the only gift he handed the
Gary's in Christmas sorry bleep that F
word out Shawn sorry and if they read
this book Ryan and they'll obviously
live a more meaningful life but the nice
thing about getting this as a gift yes
you don't even have to read it just by
having it in your stocking you will
begin to live a more meaningful life it
does the work for you
now let me tell you on Cyber Monday the
price of this book on Cyber Monday is
the exact same price it is all 365 days
a year
because we don't buy and head back we're
charging double for it on Cyber Monday
you can pay us more if you want it's
wrong no here's the thing yeah I mean of
course if you want to buy a book I don't
always recommend books as gifts because
you're you're actually committed you're
you're asking someone to commit their
time to something gifts books can make
decent gifts not necessarily our books
but just books in general if someone
wants a book I mean books in experience
it definitely can be an experience so
and that's really what Ryan needs to
look right I think experiences yeah well
let's talk about what what kind of
experience is to gift I mean for me when
I gift an experience I do a few things
one is concert tickets or tickets to
some sort of event now if it's someone
who has kids you can also gift a
babysitter for an evening that is really
helpful for folks with kids it's a great
idea so and especially if you're if
you're gifting them an experience are
you giving me a gift ideas you invested
yes you know if you know anyone who's 37
years old has five-year-old kid you want
to get them you know babysitter her a
night out maybe nice dinner but
seriously you can if you're gonna give
them an evening out quite often
including a babysitter in that is is
really helpful now obviously should be a
babysitter that they know you just don't
want to random person showing up for
their house this guy on Craigslist each
are just half of what your babysitter
charges I don't mean to be sexist but I
don't let any guys babysit Ella
[Laughter]
man yeah and so uh here's the thing I
think that if you're gifting experiences
it has to be something that is
intentional something you know they will
like so do they like going to the movies
do they like going to a play do they
like go into the theater it's really up
to you to determine what is the best
gift for them in order to do that you
have to know what they enjoy what
experiences they like it's sort of the
opposite of what he asked about gift
cards gift cards are usually pretty
crappy gifts because it's oh I'm at the
end of my shopping list I've got six
more people to shop for I'm here at the
checkout line already let's see I'll
grab one TGI Fridays and one Applebee's
and here's one for Best Buy and here's
an iTunes card it's funny cuz I love the
gift cards like I love getting them as
gifts but none of the gift cards you
just mentioned and the reason you like
getting gift cards is for something
you'll use well it's more about like PBS
for something I use but people they want
to show their appreciation so like like
when we would go to zoo Town brew uh-huh
and like there's just like a random hey
so oh yeah you're the minimalist guys
someone called in and bought you a gift
card they did this for me I think it was
for my birthday maybe or maybe it was
just a thank-you but regardless I
thought that was awesome and it's like
they got an opportunity to show their
appreciation they got to get me a gift
and I totally used up every single
dollar of that gift card I remember one
particular Christmas I needed a new
refrigerator so I actually did ask for
it wasn't a Best Buy but it was Home
Depot I was like dude I need a new
refrigerator give me as many gift cards
as you can to a to a particular place
yes so that's getting someone something
they asked for most people aren't asking
for gift cards it's a my gift cards are
often the opposite of intentional
gift-giving
yeah if they're yes but if it's an
afterthought I mean for Mariah and I
it's really about gifting something that
yes like to show our appreciation
towards someone but something that
they're going to enjoy the majority of
people that Mariah and I know
they love coffee and guess what we own a
coffee shop how convenient is that yeah
so I literally yeah I literally will
send I'll get like a case of coffee like
24 bags of coffee and we will just hand
out coffee and I'll order some chocolate
and we'll give out coffee and chocolate
for Christmas that's what we did last
year it was very well received and I got
you know thank you text messages you
know a month two months after the gifts
because I you know gave him a couple
bags of coffee that'll last a little bit
for some people and I'll you know I got
a text like two months later like hey
man I just wanna let you know I'm still
really enjoying this coffee you gave me
thank you so much and yeah it's it's
it's not that hard it's really not that
hard to if you want to give someone
something you just have to think about
what their preferences are what can you
give them that's going to support their
preferences yeah yeah I think that quite
often we do the opposite of that though
right yeah say I have to get something I
have to check this off my list I know
Josh doesn't wear ties but I'm gonna get
him a tie clip this maybe he'll start
wearing ties or you know a challenger
some wear ties but it likes the color
blue so I'm gonna give him a blue tie
it's close enough to his preference
right and that is like yeah what an
unintentional gift and that's what we're
often doing we're trying to approximate
someone's preferences and as opposed to
just figuring out what they want and
what's going to add value to their lives
because we're often told that
gift-giving is a love language
gift-giving is not a love language what
is a love language is adding value to
someone's life and we try to do that
through give the giving of gifts some of
those gifts might be physical gifts some
of them might be consumables like coffee
or chocolate
those are great gifts other gifts are
gonna be experiences sometimes your time
is the best gift because presence is
often the best present amen and so so
when we're going through our gift-giving
list there's one other thing that we
have two other things that we need to
think about and the the big thing
whenever is someone's trying to give me
a gift now I asked for them to donate
that money to the charity of my choice
that's a great great ask right now we're
trying to build this this grocery store
in West Dayton all of West Dayton
doesn't have a single grocery store
we're trying to raise
hundred thousand dollars to help them
finish building this grocery store forty
percent of the population who lives in
Dayton does not have access to grocery
hundreds of thousands of people yeah in
Dayton Ohio which is not a third world
know an area I mean this sixty second
largest city in the country crazy and
there is not a single grocery store on
the west side we're trying to change
that so Ryan and I are personally
donated $25,000 of our own money but we
could use your help as well so if you
want to help out with that you can
donate directly go to the minimalists
com or you can lash Dayton yes or you
can ask your friends and family for a
donation towards that as your Christmas
gift yeah that's exactly what I do if
you don't want to donate to that the
other good charities as well if you go
to give well.org you can always have
people donate in your name to the most
effective Charities in the world places
like the against malaria foundation and
others here's the other one though
especially for kids you know kids like
money when I was a kid that was always
the best yeah Christmas gift my aunt
would send me a card with like four
dollars in it I was so excited I
remember one my god I had a relative who
I barely ever saw an uncle my uncle but
he would give $50 quite often oh wow it
was unbelievable he was my favorite
relative oh that's great as a kid
because you realize the purchasing power
of that thing because it's so hard for
adults to know what a kid really wants
because those once as we talked about
with Hannah Murray those ones changed so
considerably over a six month span but
at $50 translated and to me getting the
things that I wanted because we were
poor man we didn't have any money and
and so my mom would often get us a good
Christmas gift the other things we would
do my brother Jerome and I we would
always do funny Christmas gifts from mom
I don't know if you remember any of this
but kind of sort of there was this one
one year where like we
left up a case of water like bottled
water and it was like this massive it's
like you get from like Walmart or Sam's
Club or something and it was this big
heavy and she thought she's getting this
great gift that she opens it up it's
just a ton of bottled water Christmas
yeah so changing expectations was
something we were doing even even as
kids but money is something that's good
and not just for kids but for people you
don't know what to get them yeah and and
sometimes it's the most helpful thing
that we can get someone I know there are
few people who work in the apartment
building that I'm in I know I'm gonna
hand them a card for Christmas and she's
gonna have 20 bucks in it and there will
be a lot more thankful for that than if
a same year with the parking attendant
guys who were write to us
yeah you better believe they're gonna
get an envelope from the minimalists for
a Christmas time yeah it's gonna be way
better than if I got them a tie clip for
sure so donate something and someone's
name to cheer and in fact if I can't
think of something if I can't think of a
gift for someone the first thing I go to
is I'm gonna donate to charity in their
name because what are they gonna say
when they open up that they get that
envelope with the charitable donation
hey look I've made $100 charitable
contribution to the Jim City Market this
co-op and Dana Ohio in your name you're
helping us build this beautiful grocery
store give people access to food we're
gonna say to you this is crap I wanted I
wanted a necktie I'm really wanted a
shirt yet how dare you how dare you
here's my tie clip that I'm never gonna
wear so yeah I think that's often that
that is my go to these days and in fact
I'm trying to think
other than Ella that's what I do for
everyone at this point yeah is I donate
to charity and so I think that that's a
good recommendation you start there
and if there's a specific need then
isn't that so much better wouldn't you
rather get that look I donated $100 to
the against malaria foundation it's so
much better than $100 gift card to TGI
Fridays yeah I definitely agree with
that man and you know I I have button
like an I have button that's not a word
but within the last few years
physical items for people so you know
it's not like I'm not personally against
buying physical gifts I think the
problem is when you can't think of a
physical gift to give someone mm-hmm
like that's when you need to okay I'm
gonna back away from this idea of going
to the mall and being inspired and
buying something physical to give this
person like you've got to start thinking
about the things that we just mentioned
absolutely and so I would start there
unless there is a physical item that
makes sense for that pertain especially
for kids that they often know what they
what they want they will be the first to
tell you they'll make their their
shopping list for fake Santa Ella knows
that Santa is fake she's lost her two
front teeth now and she just the other
night the second one fell out in the
bathtub she panicked because like if she
thought was gonna down the drain and and
she's like I wanted to put it on my
pillow for the tooth fairy I know mom's
really the tooth fairy so she said yeah
you know because we don't tell her lies
about imaginary beans it's not it's so
funny like how breaking into our house
at night we teach her yeah we teach our
kids that lying is bad but then we lie
to him about Santa Claus and the tooth
fairy and then we're like well it's okay
to lie about some things right yeah
that's a no it's a conversation that's
worth having very brief is like but we
we do play pretend with her just like
I'll play I'll pretend to be a monster
or a dragon with her she knows I'm not
an actual dragon and we'll do the same
for Santa and what we'll explain to her
that Santa isn't real but it's really
fun to pretend yeah all right Ryan I'm
gonna send you a copy not you Ryan but
Ryan from Dallas heard you got whatever
whatever copy of our book you're gonna
send me I've already got it this one
makes a great stocking stuffer as well
everything that remains it's my favorite
thing that we've ever written it's a
story about well there's a story in here
called the worst Christmas ever
oh yeah and I printed it out but I'm not
gonna read it to you but there's the the
story of a little Andy it's based on on
a true story we just changed the name
here change the name
changed the sands in the toy yeah but
the the story in there is is a real
story and it's it's called the worst
Christmas ever but it's about getting
everything you want as a kid and I'm
realizing it's actually getting more
than you asked for as a kid yeah but
sometimes that more than what you asked
for is not what you wanted right and so
the story and everything that remains
it's a memoir about the five-year
journey from us being these suit-and-tie
corporate guys to becoming the
minimalists and so Ryan from Dallas will
send you a audio book version of that or
if you want the book book for a stocking
stuffer or you put the book on a on a
iPad and then put that in the stocking I
like it it's the most expensive stocking
stuffer
all right we'd love to hear what you
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip about holiday shopping including
advice for any of our callers today
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan with time is
there it's time for our
Oh calm down we'll reinsert questions
from social media we're on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
this will Ryan and I each do our best to
answer every question which is a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
thanks to our good friend Jessica Lynne
Williams they're all over at minimal
Maxim's calm God love you Jess our first
lightning round question is from Tracy
what's the best way to encourage family
members whose love language is gift
giving to give our kids experiences such
as gymnastics instead of more stuff what
are you what are you choking on over
there buddy I'm choking on the love
language gift-giving it's so far yeah I
agree with you I don't like mocking
people but the gift-giving yeah yeah
well let me give you my pithy answer and
then we'll talk about experiences of
course you know this is this is an oldie
but a goodie so I pulled this one out of
the archives
if gift-giving is a love language then
Pig Latin is a Romance language so all
I'm really saying there is adding value
is the real love language so the best
question to really ask yourself I'm
gonna I'm gonna answer your question
with my own question and that question
is how can you help your family add
value to your kids lives
yeah because maybe they don't understand
how they can add value and so they're
going to do what they assume to be
correct and that's gifting some sort of
gift because they want to add value but
if they realize the better way to add
value is X then you have to show them
what X is yeah I totally agree all right
Maya the answer is this you can't force
loved ones to support you all you can do
is ask and Traci it's too late to start
asking for this Christmas but wait like
give yourself a two-month break yep and
then like Feb
you're talking about have your holiday
planning meeting in February just like
we did genius but instead of trying to
convince people to buy stuff it's about
convincing your family to not buy stuff
it's really about planting that seed
like February because you don't do in
January people are still like returning
all their Christmas gifts they didn't
want because they got way too many gifts
yeah so dude it's Christmas is such a I
feel like there's so many different just
feelings you have to like dance around
with with Christmas whether it's like
giving someone who expects something
getting something from someone who
expects you to enjoy this something that
they're giving you the expectation of
holding on to the gifts I mean there are
all these just just expectations I feel
like we like we have to dance around we
have to manage them better yeah during
Christmas it's it's crazy to think that
there's someone in Tracy's life who they
want to add value so they do this by
getting physical items which actually
takes away from their life it gives in a
way does the exact opposite than that
value so maybe that's the conversation
that Tracy has it's hey I know that you
really want to get our family something
I know you want to get our kids
something and that you know you gifting
a physical item this is the way that you
want to show your appreciation well if
you want to gift us something just gift
us your time or uh you know make us a
dinner you know doesn't have to be on
Christmas but yeah we'll come over for
dinner one day or or maybe we'll go out
to a movie I love going to matinees on
Christmas like that is I don't know why
but my grandma it's always packed there
too I know do my grandma like that was
kind of stuff that she's always done
growing up and like now I've got that
like you know it's cool to go see a
movie on Christmas but like that
nostalgic feeling of like oh this is
what we used to do when I was a kid
right but it becomes a sort of tradition
family tradition in a way absolutely
yeah and you can and that's not the cool
thing you can do right now is traditions
are birthed out of today's actions you
you can tweet that one Shawn boom and
why not start a new tradition it doesn't
have to be a former tradition that
someone else set up for you you know
what you can set
traditions for yourself maybe you do
what REI does on Black Friday you know
about the opt outside camp yeah in fact
let me let me read about this we got
this essay on our website called let's
talk about Black Friday and it it talks
a little bit about that here we are in
the midst of what is supposedly the most
joyous time of year the holiday shopping
season and yet why she it says the
holiday season and yet for most of us
it's the most stressful time of year at
some point Santa Claus turned corporate
in the holiday season turned into the
holiday shopping season shopping this
one word although birth from great
intentions has fundamentally changed our
outlook from blissful to grim from jolly
to anxious from celebrating Christmas to
surviving the holidays mm-hmm it's
upsetting and with consumptions vicious
inertia it seems there's no way for us
to exit the speeding train of
consumerism this Friday is the busiest
shopping day of the year
Black Friday there's a little
parenthesis here Boxing Day is the
overseas equivalent it happens the day
after Christmas overseas retailers
prepare months in advance for this day
preparation that's meant to stimulate
our insatiable desire to consume
doorbuster sales new products giant
newspaper ads TV radio billboards sale
sales sale early bird specials one day
only get the best deal act now while
supplies last
see store for details but as shiny as
its facade may be the pernicious aspects
of Black Friday are not few the
pandemonium takes that takes place on
this day as perhaps a broader metaphor
for our culture as a whole our consumer
culture on this day we consume
gluttonously without regard for the harm
we're inflicting on ourselves on this
day greed becomes ravenous on this day
we live without real meaning buying
gifts to fill a void we can't fill with
material possessions Black Friday is the
day we trample people for things we
don't
need the day after being thankful for
what we have sadly we participate in
this insanity in the name of a holiday
as if buying gifts was an ideal way to
celebrate Christmas but thankfully we
have options instead of embracing Black
Friday you can refuse to buy material
material items for people to display
your love rather you can showcase your
love caring and affection through daily
actions every day not just holidays if
you want to give gifts why not gift an
experience a nice meal tickets to a
concert a sunset on a beach after all
the best most loving gift you can give
someone as your time and undivided
attention or if that doesn't work maybe
you can buy everyone on your Christmas
list
a giant trashcan so they can throw away
all the presents they received but
didn't ask for I think the the opt
outside is actually the last line of
this essay is about opting outside um
what REI does they close their stores on
Black Friday and turn their website off
and say hey it's time for us to opt
outside go do something outdoors because
the consumption will still be here the
day after the big shopping day what a
good what a good example man cuz like
just coming from that retail world in
the loathing Black Friday
mm-hmm just loathing it as a consumer
I've never really experienced it
honestly but re I've to give Black
Friday off to their family in order to
obscure their to their to their employee
so they could spend time with their
family and their friends like that's
yeah good on them that's awesome
our next question is from middle-aged
upgrade I work in marketing what are the
ethical implications of a minimalist
trying to convince people to buy things
they almost certainly don't need and
enticing them with Black Friday in cyber
monday sales i feel like we've already
we've already talked about this i'll
just giving my short answer here this
content is birthed at the place where
our
values don't align with our actions yeah
very similar to to mine so the the short
answer is money over values is a failed
equation as in that's like what what he
middle-aged upgrade here is trying to do
here is justify making money over there
values right I mean the pithy I mean
like the I guess the less pithy answer
would be there isn't a pithy answer in
the world that's gonna make us feel
better when we put money above our
values and beliefs yeah and isn't isn't
it strange like it's okay to put money
into the equation here's we don't want
to need it above the values you can even
put it with the values you can say it
look that my values are important to me
but you know what else is important to
me feeding my family right putting a
roof over the head putting clothes on
their back sending them to school yeah
taking care of the people I care about
living a life that has at least the base
level of needs that are covered in order
to do that I'm going to have to find I'm
gonna have to marry the two I'm gonna
have to marry my values with with the
earning of an income and sometimes you
know what that means Ryan that means
earning less money yeah you know what we
earn way less money on this podcast
because we don't put advertisements on
it you and I would make more money off
of this podcast than we've ever made in
our lives doing anything else and we
simply would pepper it with
advertisements we could do pre-roll and
mineral and enroll and we could do
sponsor the this segment the right here
right now segment is sponsored by tide
and and we could do that and you and I
could literally make a million dollars a
year off of advertisements yeah easy
with the number of listeners that we
have yeah the reason we don't do that
isn't because we hate money no money I
would love if someone to give me a
million dollars
I will take your million dollars thank
you of course if however you say but I
just need you to compromise the yes
value I'm gonna give you a million
dollars but you have to start putting
advertisements into your podcast
yeah the
then I'm going to say no unless you can
find a great way that I'm not
compromising my values dude if we let's
say we took this year and sold out and
just you know made as much money as
possible I mean I would just be the king
of who gives a [ __ ] it's like yeah you
know maybe we could sell out and have a
million bucks in the bank or two million
bucks to the bank whatever it may be but
Legman if you're sitting on it within
why yeah if you're sitting on a pile of
two million dollars but you have forsook
your values you forsook your beliefs you
forsaken the people around you what do
you you got nothing but money I mean
that's if you have if all you have is
money you're the loneliest person in the
world well that was the video we watched
what was that was that the excess
podcast yeah yeah it was the excess
podcast last episode yeah or two
episodes ago we we talked about or we
played the video where he's like if all
you have is money then you're the
poorest person in the world yeah and so
right now what we're talking about is
figure out what your values are and it
sounds to me like this gentleman here
middle-age upgrade is struggling because
what he's doing for money doesn't align
with the person that he wants to be and
that's when we start experiencing that
discontent yeah yes Ryan we have one
more question here and this question is
from Katie Katie says how can we have a
clutter free Christmas with kids I want
them to have found fond memories of
Christmas but without all the crap so
we're gonna talk about that we're gonna
talk about avoiding buying them crap
we're gonna talk about some of the
things you can do for your kids
specifically and if you'd like to hear
our answer to that question you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimalist private podcast
feed available exclusively to our
patreon supporters so if you want to
support the show and keep it 100%
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes
the minimalist private podcast feed
includes our ask the minimalist anything
episodes we're recording one of those
today actually you can ask us anything
unreleased recordings of our live events
and the entire back catalogue of past
private episodes once you become a
supporter you'll receive a personal link
to our private podcast feed so that it
plays in the normal podcast player that
you're using to listen to this podcast
right now you can find all the details
and all the good stuff over at the
minimalists comm slash support and here
is a snippet from this week's private
PostScript episode when kids expect the
world and you well what's that Damien
rice line you asked for the mountains
and I gave you the sea and like that's
sort of the problem right like kids
often want the mountains and we're we go
out of our way to give them something
equally magnificent but they wanted
something that was magnificent but
different and so sometimes we have to
shape their expectations right yeah and
those expectations don't come from well
I'm just gonna buy you a large amount of
crap because I can give you the mountain
the mountain of junk and you're gonna
get excited for a moment but an hour
later two hours after Christmas morning
is over there's a bunch of wrapping
paper strewn throughout the living room
a bunch of unplayed with new toys and
there's one or two things that might be
exciting to them those are the things
you should focus on and let go of the
rest
[Music]
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion of the shows where we each talk
about someone who has added value to our
lives recently so Ryan you and I were at
a concert a couple weeks ago with the
Gregory Allen is a call yes in the who
open up for them that something reads
the I don't remember who opened up the
the girl the girl band um yeah okay well
you keep talking I'll think of in a
second yeah it was a great open I never
knew their name so yeah yeah they're
they're a solid opener for sure but uh
I've seen him twice this year I saw him
once in Missoula I saw him once here in
LA I've probably seen him four times
total and he always puts on the most
amazing show and so we had this this gal
Carrie she came out to us at the
beginning of the concert and she was
like hey you're the minimalist I'll just
listen your podcast
you should definitely recommend going to
see Gregory Allen is a call on your
podcast I'm like you know what you're
right we should and plus he has a new
album so I'm gonna wreck if you can't
see him in person if he's not coming to
where you are although he tours all over
the place but he's not coming to where
you are if he's already been there then
you can check out his new album it's
called evening machines and we're gonna
play at the end of this episode we'll
play one of my favorite tracks from from
that album it's called chemicals we'll
play that at the end we'll play them out
with that yeah that's a great that's a
great album it's I think they're The
Wandering reads that's who opened up
form anyway great ban that's also a
great band uh man you know I've been
using the peloton so the apartment
building that Mariah and I live in they
have to peloton bikes in the the the
apartment gym there so basically a
peloton is your own private like
spinning class yeah so they're super
expensive so I'm not recommending that
people go out and buy a peloton because
if they didn't have them in our gym I'm
not sure Mariah and I would wouldn't we
definitely wouldn't have two of them so
but what I will recommend is I know
you'd put two of them in that tiny
apartment get rid of your bed yeah I
don't even know man but what I will
recommend is a spinning class like I
always thought spinning classes were
kind of cheesy mm-hmm kind of hokey well
they are a little bit like I've
oh yeah I've realized that like it's the
one place where you have permission to
be to be cheesy right to be platitude
know like if right if you really want to
have a career as a karaoke singer hmm
then become a a soul cycle instructor
right because or the peloton instructor
whatever they're always singing along to
all the songs and yeah but like you you
give them like they have license to be
cheesy and have these aspirational slash
inspirational sayings yeah yeah I do it
at least twice a week I have a bike in
our house now but I was going I realized
I was spending so much money on soul
cycle and plus it's way less convenient
like going to the class repeatedly but
it's a big purchase so you have to you
have to really think it through I talked
about in a previous episode really
considering that person with several
months considering it and budgeting for
it appropriately because what every man
yeah but but but it's more expensive to
not live a healthy lifestyle right
absolutely but yeah I'm not even
recommending an actual peloton I think
though once you start taking spin
classes then you start to think like oh
how can I do these at home but like what
what I'm getting at is is a spinning
class for me is like the perfect cardio
workout because what happens in LA when
I go to these circuit training classes
when Mariah and I go I go with like dr.
Ryan green our physician and like he's
just running circle like I feel like I'm
practicing to take the class like one
day I'll actually be able to take the
full class and like keep up but until
then I just like get a bunch of
practices in I'd be like if I went to go
like like play with the Utah Jazz right
now right like I'm okay at basketball
but but can you imagine like if I went
to go just like even like go practice
with them I I would look stupid yeah
it's like me surfing I don't really surf
as much as I practice certain practice
falling so forth but you know the thing
is is like the the spinning class what I
love about it is I don't feel I don't
feel like I am at the bottom of the
so I don't feel like I can be the middle
pack but also at the pacing of it is
like it's incredible man like it I leave
feeling energized it's the only it's the
it's literally the only exercise that I
do were afterwards I'm like oh I want to
go lift some weights like that the first
spinning class I ever took was with was
it SoulCycle with you and bags and Nate
and Rochelle and and and me and Mariah
and dr. Ryan Greene and after that class
Mariah and I went and did leg day cuz
like we were so energy from that from
that that cardio but like anyone out
there who's looking for just like a good
cardio workout and looking for something
a little bit different I would highly
recommend a spinning class it is it's
it's it's it's just very invigorating I
was gonna say it's fun but it's not fun
as much as it is invigorating well I
think it's fun for a lot of people I
think a lot of people really really
enjoy it but here's the other thing is
I've noticed there's all different skill
levels in the class when you go it's
there are people who are less skilled
than me which is pretty amazing somehow
you know Ike and there are people more
skilled than me which is pretty amazing
you know I can barely ride a bike I
almost fell off the bike but know what I
mean what I realized is like like it is
you can go at your own pace even amongst
a class of 30 or 40 people and and
you're not required because it's a it's
a darker room and you're not forced to
like burn yourself out but you will get
into that discomfort zone where you want
it's where you want to be uncomfortable
cuz that's the place from which you're
going to grow and that's what it is that
I love about the class man is it pushes
you just beyond your comfort zone and
you get to decide where that is and
everyone has a different line of where
their comfort zone is but that's that
that hit the nail on the head man with
the spinning class is it gets you to
your comfort zone in just a little bit
past yeah but that is what is it so
energizing about it I found that I'm
competing with myself more than anything
right I beat my personal record
yesterday which is really hard for me to
do like this there are a few days where
I have like these personal I'll make how
did I
do that and there are other days where
I'm so far behind it but at least I got
in the half hour anyway right and that's
what you feel good about absolutely
regardless Flay okay I didn't eat my
personal record yet but I spent my 30
minutes on the bike it's so funny
because you know when you're pedaling
and always shows your personal best yeah
and I look at that personal best and I'm
like I have no idea how the hell I hit
that right I have not I have not got
there in the least last two or three
weeks but like look at that number I'm
like how do I even get there I know
right yeah yeah I think the key is you
have to you have to start out of the
gate hot yeah in order to keep up with
your with your personal record let's
move on the right here right now is
where we talk about what's going on the
lives of the minimalist so we got Ryan
here's what we have for them the special
holiday weekend we have Thursday we have
Friday oh my god Saturday we have Sunday
let's talk about Thursday this Thursday
is Thanksgiving yes I tweeted something
today Ryan I said I am I am thankful for
everything that I don't have and I meant
that sort of as a double entendre like
I'm thankful I don't have a bunch of
excess stuff in my life that I got rid
of so I'm thankful I don't have that
stuff anymore
but also lemon we talked about about
what real love is we were talking with P
Rollins real love is is giving what you
don't have to someone who doesn't want
it I'm glad you know I don't have a
major sickness I'm glad that I don't
have think about be giving you a tie
clip here this is love dammit I'm glad I
don't have toxic relationships in my
life I'm so thankful that that not for
just the things I have expressing
gratitude for that but being I think
it's also important to have gratitude
for the things we don't want in our
lives and keeping those those things at
bay it's so funny man when I get down
like I will remind myself of like hey
man like you know you've got you've got
the ability to like run up this mountain
right now if you want to or you got the
you know it's like idea appreciating
what you don't have I know exactly what
you're saying like hey I've got my
health I don't have a sickness lingering
over me right now
like I can totally eat what I want I
mean it's yeah it's so important to
recognize those things
yeah I'm thankful I don't have the
corporate career of yesteryear and I
decided to walk away from that and I'm
thankful for a lot of things now Ryan
you and I did ate an entire video every
Wednesday we do a living room
conversation we did a special
Thanksgiving conversation called what
are the minimalist thankful for this
Thanksgiving so you can check that out
on our YouTube channel we'll also put a
link to it in the show notes and then
this Friday this Friday is Black Friday
and well we're encouraging you all
we're obviously as we've mentioned we've
partnered up with the Jim City Market
and you can buy a brick on Black Friday
so there is a essay on our website right
now the minimalists comm slash brick now
a brick costs about $1 to buy right so
for every dollar you donate to this it
doesn't go to go straight to the the Jim
City Market nonprofit organization for
every dollar you donate you're
essentially buying a brick to build this
this new building this new battery store
on the west side of Dayton so if you
want to contribute and by the way you
can buy a bunch of other bricks they
make great stocking stuffers you must
act now though well I mean quite a
little this bricks before they're all
bought out you you do need to act by end
of the year that's when we need to try
to get this hundred thousand dollars to
them by the end of this year yeah and so
if you want to help out you could buy
bricks for every literally you can earn
a dollar one dollar for every one on
your Christmas list then print out the
dollar that you donated for them put it
in the envelope stick it in their
stocking or give it handed to them and
say look I bought a brick for you and on
your behalf for this charity we're gonna
provide food for families in the second
hungriest city in the country Dayton
Ohio so if you're interested in doing
that please help out the minimalists
comm slash your brick you can buy a
brick for Black Friday and then of
course this Saturday is screen with
Saturday you can find out more about
that over at the minimalists comm slash
screen lists we've been doing this for
over a month now
close to two months at this point and
enjoying the we're enjoying the process
of that we're learning a whole lot I
think we'll end up probably doing a
whole episode about screen --less
Saturdays at some point once have had a
maybe a quarter of screen with Saturdays
under our belt we could talk a lot about
the experiences and how we're going to
leverage that knowledge going forward
yeah my favorite part is about
Screenland Saturdays is just the being
able to let go of any obligations
it's like Mariah and I walked to
squirrel from our place it's like an
hour and 20 minute walk my favorite
restaurant in LA and took us like
probably two hours walk back as we
stopped for coffee and we stopped to go
get him tiger which is on the way and a
couple other places but it's like
there's like I'm not beholding anything
on Saturdays it's like the most
important people in my life if they need
to get a hold of me on Saturday they
know that I'm the wrong person to get a
hold of if they have an emergency on
Saturdays right I'm probably the wrong
person to get a hold of if there's an
emergency pretty much all the time yeah
I don't know exactly what I'm going to
do to help you well it's funny cuz like
I figured who it was they're like I put
them on my out of office reply hey I'm
out of town if this is emergency call me
and then I was getting emails back we're
like oh it's an emergency but I don't
have your phone number and they're like
if you don't have my phone number I'm
the wrong person to get a hold of for an
emergency that's happening in your life
like yeah totally yeah alright so screen
with Saturday is the minimalists comm /
screen list if you want to participate
in that there's three different ways to
participate you can get off social media
you can get off that's that that's the
first way so that's the easiest one
right the next is I'm gonna give get rid
of all of the the Internet connected
devices so like the computer the the
tablet the phone or you can go
completely screen lists no TV no glowing
screens whatsoever and so all the
details are over there on our website
and then simple Sundays every Sunday I'm
not sure if you know this but we send
out an email every Sunday from our
website if you're interested in
receiving emails from us use it some
sort of writing
for example we we will just put a short
essay about living simply simple advice
for simple living you can find that over
at the minimalists comm just put your
email address at the top will also send
you the show notes anytime we put out a
new podcast episode of course we'll
never send you any promotions or spam or
junk or we're never sell your
information to advertisers unless they
give us a million dollars no all right
if you want to comment on this episode
you can do so over at youtube.com slash
the minimalists there's also several new
website websites on our website or is it
several new websites on our essays
something like that a bunch of new
writings from the minimalists over at
the minimalists com also on YouTube
right now you can find quickie episodes
of the minimalist podcast you can find
living room conversations and coming
pretty soon a house tour from the
minimalists and ryan what else you got
from us I got some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out my name is Louis Missouri
I had a response to the excess
fashionista I also really enjoy fashion
but also like to keep us smaller closet
I use an app called sidewalk just
currently free and you upload your
closet and it takes outfits for you I'm
according to the weather which is really
nice and it kind of sees what color
palette you like and also what things
that you don't normally wear so that you
can kind of get rid of it what I do with
the stuff that I don't worry often so I
trade it out at some place like
crossroads Trading Company or Avalon
exchange with buy sell trade so then
you're not adding to the live fill with
your clothes and then you're also not
buying anything new and something I'm
enjoyed for a long time it's been
working pretty well I understand you
want to look cool but have a smaller
father those two things really help me
hi this is Karras from the Atlanta area
I'm calling about your episode on Tasha
number 146 when I was 16 I did a couple
of pageants yet no judging there one of
the questions they asked for the emcee
to read while contestants walked across
the stage was what do you collect since
I didn't collect anything I said
memories best answer ever and help me
win for sure it's a great thing to
collect doesn't take up any space
there's endless space for it there's
nothing to maintain really so for those
looking to get rid of their current
collection try replacing it with a
collection of memories
I have a comment to follow-up concern
one of the originals have about music
pieces having aesthetic or a collection
of something that will really hydrate
value prevent at one time but it was
missing a piece or two and they were
hesitant to get rid of it
I had conversation about this very thing
but in a different context with a friend
who is an eBay reseller the part-time
thing for her
she shops estate sales and in her
experience but the spell bells are the
missing pieces and she discovered this
by accident when she Hara
I think the Harry Potter DVD collection
that had one missing DVD and she decided
to see you and what else was missing the
DVD maybe one that she had and they sold
quickly so she can't sell corn anywhere
for example dishes but people will get
into bidding wars trying to get the lid
for nothing sometimes missing pieces are
missing for you but they were made in
pieces fill in the blanks for someone
else alright so that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalist give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if you leave
here with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listen yo we'll see you next time
alright let's play i'm out ryan with
chemicals from Gregory Allen is a
college new album evening machines enjoy
that unless you're watching this on
youtube then click somewhere here or
here or here I don't know see you later
minimus